Довжелезні черги до військкоматів,
які утворилися в перші дні вторгнення Росії в Україну,
на другому році повномасштабної війни змінилися на…
Ви хто мені?
Я представник ТЦК.
Мені все одно, що ви представник ТЦК.
Або ж…
І напруга в українському суспільстві продовжує рости.
Я втратила брата на війні
й я не хочу втратити ще чоловіка.
Мені складно сказати:
шкода тих, хто там, й шкода тих, хто тут.
Обговорення нового законопроєкту про посилення мобілізації
вже викликало суспільний резонанс.
Змінилася й ситуація на кордоні.
В кінці 2023-го року на кордоні суворіше стали
перевіряти чоловіків, що прагнуть виїхати з України.
У чоловіків, яким дозволено залишати країну попри воєнний стан,
почали вимагати додаткові документи про військовий облік в ТЦК.
У Державній прикордонній службі пояснили суворіший контроль
зростанням кількості підробних документів.
Посилені перевірки на кордоні спричинили черги.
Ситуація на кордоні вплинула на суспільні настрої й
налаштувала деяких українців проти посилення мобілізації, вважають експерти.
Як і мобільні блокпости, які розгорнули
в українських містах напередодні нового року.
Мають бути зрозумілими критерії невиїзду чоловіків за кордон.
Бо зараз зупинили людей на кордоні, пояснити нічого не можуть,
тицяють пальцем один на одного: військкомати на прикордонників,
прикордонники на військкомати.
Урядовий законопроєкт зареєстрували в парламенті
на Різдво, ввечері 25 грудня.
У ньому уряд запропонував, зокрема,
знизити призовний вік з 27 до 25 років.
А ще - встановити обмеження прав громадян,
які ухиляються від взяття на військовий облік
та проходження військової служби.
Також Кабмін запропонував змінити процедуру військового обліку
призовників, військовозобов’язаних та резервістів.
А з переліку висновків військово-лікарської комісії
уряд запропонував виключити висновок про "обмежену придатність" до військової служби.
Для того, щоб посилити мобілізацію, я вважаю, потрібно,
щоб допомагала нашим хлопцям держава.
Щоб воїни не самі себе одягали, а щоб була допомога.
Мобілізація не повинна бути примусовою.
Бо невмотивовані люди на фронті навіщо потрібні?
Про це кажуть й деякі військові: користі від тих, кого примусово мобілізували, мало.
Водночас українські захисники, які воюють з перших днів вторгнення,
потребують ротації.
Мій товариш, комбат одного з підрозділів, говорить:
"Із Сил оборони є три двері: на небо, в госпіталь і в тюрму".
І це дуже неправильно. Ці люди майже два роки
дуже важко працюють. Вони мають знати: а доки служити.
Ми ж не в ситуації тотальної мобілізації, коли нема на кого міняти.
Ну давайте просто порахуємо.
До війни в Україні було не менше 35 млн.
Окей, 10 виїхало. 25.
Беремо половину - 12,5.
З них точно 5 млн - чоловіки, придатні до військової служби.
Служить мільйон.
Тобто у нас в 4 рази є більший запас.
На суспільне сприйняття законопроєкту
вплинула відсутність комунікації влади з суспільством,
вважає політолог Ігор Рейтерович.
Подібні рішення потребують консультацій із зацікавленими сторонами,
зокрема й з представниками громадянського суспільства ще на етапі підготовки.
От те, що відбувалося в закритому режимі,
треба вже було робити з зацікавленими сторонами.
Там наразі була присутня лише одна сторона - Генштаб ЗСУ.
Ніяких федерацій роботодавців, інститутів громадянського суспільства,
зокрема й тих, які опікуються громадянами з особливими потребами,
там не було.
Я сам колишній військовий, ветеран.
Те, що зараз з нашими хлопцями роблять, це неправильно.
Неправильний підхід зробили.
Вони мали б нашим хлопцям допомагати,
що на передку, що тут, але вони тупо кинули всіх.
І чому зараз хлопці, чоловіки не хочуть воювати…
Розумієте, якби хоч чимось допомагали нашим хлопцям,
то було б все набагато краще.
Мабуть, є якесь відхилення від справедливості, від правди.
Прості хлопці йдуть, а "жирні" - ні.
На тлі обговорень нового законопроєкту
почалися й публічні дискусії - у ЗМІ та серед нардепів -
про можливий відкуп від мобілізації.
Я вважаю, що це на совісті у людини.
Я проти. Хтось йде воювати, а хтось йде відкуповуватися.
Ми маємо мати відчуття національної справедливості в суспільстві.
Дуже багато хлопців воюють, які заробляли великі гроші
й могли б це зробити, але пішли воювати.
Тому я думаю, що нам треба від цих грошових цензів відходити.
Думку про те, що офіційна можливість "відкупитися"
від мобілізації принесе більше шкоди, ніж користі,
поділяє й ветеран АТО та військовий аналітик Євген Дикий.
Наприклад, 11 бійців.
Це піхотне відділення, а по-хорошому - на піхотний взвод. 30 бійців.
І ти повністю їх утримуєш: із зарплатами, броніками,
із шоломами, з усім. Я тоді так, як прагматик би вважав,
що від цієї людини більше користі в тилу,
ніж як від одного бійця в цьому самому взводі.
Якби наші заможні "буратіни" напряму утримували
кожен по взводу бійців - це було б корисно, але я розумію,
що введення цієї норми може дати більше шкоди, ніж користі.
Треба, щоб влада переконала суспільство,
що мобілізація - це не податок на бідність і чесність.
На сьогодні служіння у війську - це податок на чесність,
ті хто міг відкупитися, але совість не дозволила, і бідність -
ті, хто не міг відкупитися.
В містах набагато менший відсоток мобілізації, ніж в селах.
У великих містах набагато менший, ніж у маленьких містах.
Тобто чітко корелюється з доходом.
В Америці це лотерея.
Депутат ти, не депутат, працюєш в адміністрації.
Витягнув лотерею - вперед на фронт.
Утім, попри численні зауваження до законопроєкту,
опитані DW експерти запевняють –
подальша мобілізація Україні необхідна.
У нас насправді немає вибору, точніше - він є тільки з двох опцій.
У нас є вибір: або достатньо масова мобілізація,
така, як у орків, або капітуляція.
Власне, третього варіанту нам не пропонують.
У нас немає варіанту якихось компромісних угод, домовленостей.
Так само у нас нема варіанту 32 млн людей іммігрувати.
Тому вибір дуже простий: або ми проводимо масову мобілізацію,
або ми приймаємо те, що оті люди, які воюють зараз,
ще якийсь час фронт протримаються, а далі - прийдуть орки.
9 січня голова комітету з питань національної безпеки,
оборони та розвідки Олександр Завітневич заявив,
що запропонований Кабміном законопроєкт
має низку суперечливих положень,
тож зазнає суттєвих змін під час розгляду у парламенті.